and 2004 became a unarmed military
observer with the African Union and
Darfur Sudan all I had was a camera pan
it in the paper I was totally unprepared
for what I'd see I'm a captain the
Marine Corps I'm an infantry officer I
just commanded the company 330 Marines
and so I decided to get out and without
really any idea what I was gonna do I
found a job on the internet said patrol
leader Sudan
he said petróleo Sudan that sounds great
so I wouldn't picked up a few books
about Sudan and started reading my job
was to go monitor a ceasefire I was
going to be in charge of a three-man
team and we would go out and investigate
and monitor what is monitoring a
ceasefire really mean
the Sudanese government and rebels are
in final negotiations for a peace accord
that would put an end to a two decade
long civil war between the predominantly
Muslim north and the animist and
Christian South meanwhile a separate
conflict in the Darfur region of western
Sudan has claimed thousands of lives and
displaced as many as 1 million people
out of a population of seven million
Gretchen I had to write you to get this
out of my mind I don't know whether or
not you're aware about the African
Union's recent statements they have
released a report that states that there
is some evidence that individuals have
been chained and burned alive by the
Janjaweed I've seen these photos from a
confidential au report I'm not permitted
to send them nor do I wish on you the
same dreams that I've had as a result of
these photos the individuals that were
burned or children from a girls school
and their families that had tried to
save them the photos were the most
disturbing thing that I've ever seen I
saw girls that had their hands bound by
makeshift handcuffs huddled together and
burned alive men strewn all over the
village burned alive only because they
were trying to protect their family the
entire village lay in ashes if these
photos were released to the public
there would be troops in here in a
matter of days
the people of Sudan are scared the fear
if they speak out against the government
that they will be imprisoned I was
talking to two individuals
confidentially the other day and was
basically asking them to tell me what
their thoughts were about the government
and the situation in Darfur they said
that there is no gray area
it is either genocide or not are people
being killed because they are Africans
and not Arabs yes I'm afraid that we
will be hearing about Sudan for a long
time to come